- [Voiceover] "At time t is
greater than or equal to zero,
"a particle moving along
a curve in the xy-plane
"has position x of t and y of t."
So its coordinate is given
by the parametric function
x of t, and y-coordinate by the
parametric function, y of t.
"With velocity vector v of t is equal to,"
and the x component of the velocity vector
is cosine of t squared,
and the y component of the velocity vector
is e to the 0.5t.
"At t equals one,
"the particle is at
the point 3, comma, 5."
Is at the point 3, comma, five.
All right.
"Find the x-coordinate of
the position of the particle
"at time t is equal to two."
All right, so how do we think about this?
Well, you could view the
x-coordinate at time t equals two.
So let's say, so we
could say x at time two,
which they don't give that to us directly,
but we could say that's
going to be x of one
plus some change in x
as we go from t equals
one to t equals two.
But what is this going to be?
Well, we know what the velocity is.
And so the velocity,
especially the x component,
and we can really focus on the x component
for this first part
'cause we only wanna know
the x-coordinate of the
position of the particle.
Well, we know the x component of velocity
as a function of t
is cosine of t squared.
And if you take your velocity
in a certain dimension
and then multiply it times
a very small change in time,
in a very small change in time, dt,
this would give you your
very small change in x.
If you multiply velocity
times change in time,
it'll give you a displacement.
But what we can do is we can
sum up all of the changes
in time from t equals one to t equals two.
Remember, this is the change in x
from t equals one
to t is equal to two.
So what we have right over here,
we can say that x of two,
which is what we're trying to solve,
is going to be x of one,
and they give that at time equals one,
the particle is at the
point three, comma, five.
Its x-coordinate is three.
So this right over here is three.
And then our change in x from t equals one
to t equals two is going
to be this integral.
The integral from t
equals one to t equal two
of cosine of t squared, dt.
And just to make sure we
understand what's going on here,
remember, how much are we
moving over a very small dt?
Well, you take your
velocity in that dimension
times dt, it'll give you a
displacement in that dimension,
and then we sum 'em all
up from t equals one
to t equals two.
And in this part of the AP test,
we're allowed to use calculators
and so let's use one.
All right.
So there's my calculator.
And I can evaluate.
So let's see, I wanna evaluate three
plus the definite integral.
I click on Math,
and then I can scroll down
to function integral, right there.
The definite integral of,
and I make sure I'm in radian mode,
that's what you should assume,
unless they tell you otherwise.
Cosine of t squared, now
I'll use x as my variable
of integration, so I'll say cosine of x,
cosine of x squared.
And then my variable of integration is x,
so I'm really integrating
of x squared, dx,
but it'll give the same value,
comma, from one
until two,
and now let the calculator
munch on it a little bit,
and I get approximately 2.557.
So this is approximately
2.55,
2.557.
Let me make sure that I added the three.
Yeah, three plus that definite integral
from one to two.
2.557.
And I just rounded that.
So there you go.